Hallöchen ihr Lieben!
Heute gibt's ein richtig leckeres Abendessen bzw. ein Iftar-Essen oder auch außerhalb von Ramadan ein Mittagessen.
Wir machen nämlich gefüllte Kartoffeln mit Hackfleisch.
Ich find's soo lecker, ich liebe ja die Kombination aus Kartoffeln und Hackfleisch.
Und das Rezept ist eigentlich gar nicht so aufwendig
weil wir machen das jetzt fertig, schieben das in den Ofen und danach können wir uns anderen Dingen widmen.
Und zuallererst sollten wir die Kartoffeln vorbereiten.
Ich nehme vorwiegend festkochende Kartoffeln.
Ich schreibe euch übrigens alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben wie immer unten in die Infobox.
Und die Kartoffeln, die werden jetzt zuallererst natürlich geschält.
Dann werde ich unten etwas abschneiden damit es gerade gleich in der Pfanne liegen kann.
Dann werde ich noch oben was abschneiden und anschließend aushöhlen.
Und das Aushöhlen funktioniert tatsächlich am allerbesten mit einem Teelöffel.
Also arbeitet euch von oben immer mal wieder tiefer rein und dann habt ihr das als Endergebnis.
Ich glaube man erkennt auch ganz gut: Die sind jetzt nicht soo dick, aber auch nicht zu dünn.
Und so sind sie perfekt.
Die sind übrigens noch nicht gegart und das ist auch gut so,
denn dann sparen wir uns die Zeit und das gart dann einfach später zusammen mit dem Hackfleisch im Backofen.
Zu meinem Hackfleisch gebe ich jetzt auch schon die Gewürze
und außerdem noch etwas Gemüse in Form von Zwiebeln und roter Paprika
und verknete das dann einfach mit den Händen.
So, Zwiebeln, rote Paprika und Knoblauch sind drin.
Die roten Paprika habe ich nur Hamza zuliebe reingegeben weil er sie total mag.
Ihr könnt auch anderes Gemüse reingeben oder das Gemüse ganz weglassen.
Und jetzt gebe ich noch Salz, Pfeffer und Kreuzkümmel rein.
Und das wäre dann auch schon unsere Füllung!
Und das gebe ich dann einfach - verknete ich natürlich vorher - und gebe das dann in meine ausgehöhlten Kartoffeln.
Dat wird lecker!
Och wisst ihr was? Ich finde hier passt noch Petersilie rein!
Die gebe ich gleich noch obendrüber aber im Fleisch macht die sich auch ganz gut!
So, die Kartoffeln sind jetzt fertig befüllt und jetzt geht alles wirklich ruck-zuck!
Also der Ofen ist auch schon vorgeheizt, da sage ich euch aber die Backzeit gleich noch.
Und jetzt habe ich hier noch für die ich sag mal "typisch türkische" Soße Paprikamark.
Ihr könnt auch Tomatenmark nehmen aber ich finde an der Stelle Paprikamark einfach ein bisschen intensiver.
Da gebe ich jetzt heißes Wasser mit rein, das schon aufgekocht war gerade. Also es ist wirklich sehr heiß.
So, und dann kommt da noch Salz, Pfeffer und Thymian mit dazu.
Eigentlich könnt ihr hier noch alle Gewürze nehmen, die ihr gerne mögt.
Also ich mache das auch manchmal mit Paprikapulver oder wenn ich mal voll mutig bin
mit ein bisschen Chiliflocken, das geht auch.
Aber heute hab ich mir gedacht: Lieber nicht so scharf
weil dann hat man am nächsten Tag auch immer so viel Durst, gerade während Ramadan.
Okay, ein bisschen Pul Biber..
[Hamza] Pul Biber ist doch nicht scharf!
[Kiki] Nee, nicht so aber für uns beide schon!
[Hamza] Mach noch ein bisschen mehr rein, komm!
[Kiki] Nee Hamza!
[Hamza] Willst du's drauf ankommen lassen?
[Kiki] Komm, nur noch ein bisschen. Und dann reicht's aber wirklich!
Du wirst es so bereuen später!
Okay, und jetzt machen wir folgendes:
Wir geben jetzt alle in eine Auflaufform oder was ich mache, da habe ich sie:
Ich gebe das in meine 20-er Pfanne.
Da habe ich den Griff schon abgemacht weil das ja in den Backofen kommt.
Ich finde das einfach schick, dass man das direkt darin servieren kann.
Und jetzt haben wir ja auch noch unsere Kartoffeln übrig und zwar die ausgehöhlten.
Die natürlich nicht wegschmeißen!
Das ist eine ganze Menge und das wäre total schade, das jetzt einfach zu entsorgen.
Daher gebe ich das einfach jetzt so auf den Boden.
Und an der Stelle könnt ihr auch Gemüse mit reingeben, das ihr mögt.
Ich hab mir gedacht weil das auch schon so ein typisch türkisches Rezept ist,
das heißt nämlich auf Türkisch patates dolması. Und sogar kıymalı patates dolması!
[Kiki] Hamza komm, sprich mal nach! Kıymalı!
[Hamza] Kıymalı.
[Kiki] Patates.
[Hamza] Patates.
[Kiki] Dolması.
[Hamza] Dolması.
[Kiki] Cool!
[Hamza] Also nochmal: Kıymalı.. patates.. dolması!
Ja, richtig gut! So, jetzt gebe ich hier noch Spitzpaprika mit rein.
Und dann kommen einfach nur die Kartoffeln dazu, die Tomatensoße
und dann kommt das in den Ofen, allerdings mit dem Glasdeckel obendrauf.
Falls ihr jetzt keine Pfanne habt mit Glasdeckel, was auch in den Backofen darf,
Dann nehmt eine Auflaufform mit Alufolie oder bestellt sie euch bei mir im Shop, Werbung an der Stelle!
Verlinke ich euch in die Infobox!
[Hamza] Willst du wissen, wie es auf Arabisch heißt?
[Kiki] Ja, sag mal!
[Hamza] Weiß ich auch nicht!
[Kiki] Was heißt "gefüllt" auf Arabisch?
[Hamza] Ich glaube, es müsste eigentlich mahshi sein!
[Hamza] Also so batata mahshi.
[Kiki] Batata mahshi!
[Hamza] Ja, denke ich. Ich weiß es nicht, ich will nichts Falsches sagen!
[Kiki] Okay!
So ein bisschen Salz noch für die Kartoffeln.
Aber nicht zu viel, wir haben in der Soße ja auch schon Salz.
Und die gefüllten Kartoffeln brauchen jetzt im vorgeheizten Backofen bei 240° C Ober- und Unterhitze
ca. 40-45min.
Ihr könnt ja auch die Probe machen und eine mal durchschneiden.
Das Fleisch wird auf jeden Fall gar in der Zeit.
Guckt auch, dass die Kartoffeln von allen Seiten schön durchgaren
und dann könnt ihr das Ganze noch mit Petersilie bestreut servieren.
Und ich werde dazu noch ein bisschen Joghurt servieren.
So, ihr Lieben ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel Spaß beim Nachkochen.
Ich hoffe, dass ihr das fleißig nachkochen werdet, denn es schmeckt wirklich ausgezeichnet.
Und bei uns wird's das auch definitiv öfter geben,
das gab's auch schon echt lange nicht mehr.
Ich bin auch ziemlich hungrig muss ich sagen, wir haben jetzt noch so 20-25min bis zum Iftar.
Dann werde ich euch in der Story wie immer mitnehmen.
Folgt uns auf Instagram wenn ihr das nicht schon längst tut und folgt auch gerne dem Vlog Account
wenn ihr mehr Vlogs von uns sehen möchtet.
Und dann würde ich einfach mal sagen: Bis zum nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen, Tschüss!